this guy I could tell you're married you
know how I could tell because that's
been your going out shirt for about six
years
look at the hand I just saw that shirt I
was like that shirt was in fashion about
four years ago she made you put that on
yeah I told him I'm good at this I know
when a man gets made to put on some by
his wife
all right
huh Pakistani what the Pakistani person
calls it Pakistani
I'm assuming your wife is not Pakistani
she's Cuban oh all right you came
to Miami all right
what's your favorite thing about being
married
okay fair enough
I just got them into a fight I didn't
mean to but it did I know a car fight
when I see one I feel bad I started it
but I also think it's hilarious because
I've been a victim of that many
times where you think everything is good
and then all of a sudden she gets pissed
off and then you're in the car trying to
distract her and like that
you hungry you wanna pull get some
desserts somewhere